All right.
To introduce you to temporal
difference learning.
It helps to have a little bit of
context about reinforcement learning in
a more general way.
So we can see how
the different methods for
doing reinforcement
learning fit together.
>> Okay.
>> So, I'm going to think about
reinforcement learning this way.
Remember we talked about SARS,
the state-action-reward sequence.
So, I'm in a state.
I take an action.
I get a reward back.
I end up in a new state.
I take a new action.
I get a new reward.
And this just continues, so
I put a little Kleene star after it.
To indicate that this is some
sequence of state, action, rewards.
That's what comes as input to
a reinforcement learning algorithm.
And what the reinforcement learning
algorithm produces as output
is a policy.
>> Sure, that makes sense.
Hey, I got a quick notational
question for you though.
>> Sure.
>> Should that really be a Kleene star,
or should that be a plus?
Well I'm being a little bit
lax with notation here.
But I'm imagining that,
even if you give a reinforcement
learning algorithm no history at all.
It could still come out
with an initial policy.
>> Sure that makes sense.
In fact, I guess that's true for
every algorithm we've ever talked about.
>> I think so.
I mean it could be just be a default
policy like in all states take whatever
the first action is.
But the fact of the matter is over time.
The interesting case is when we've
had some amount of history and
we're trying to map
that to some behavior.
>> Okay I'm on the same page.